all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 104 it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable and the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
and we've got Google stadia its effect
on Xbox Sony and Nintendo Master Chief
collection skips play anywhere and ps5
ray-tracing to discuss so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce a lady
it was not only a great friend and Ally
to the realm but whom the ILP is truly
honored to have as a supporter in our
infancy stages whether it be her
passionate hot takes on the gaming
industry outstanding news articles or
dedication to playing the games we love
there is no doubt gaming is truly in her
blood introducing the director and
editor-in-chief of real games Mediacom
and the host of the rgm podcast the
originator of what truly grinds a game
was gear and creator of the funniest
Twitter poll pitting her for we go vs.
the division two dogs on extraction live
from Australia and making her triumphant
return back into the realm of the Lords
my girl lady Bella rise how you doing
sis good evening gentleman wow that was
quite the introduction Thank You
Connelly it's always an honor to be back
at the round table absolute pleasure
long overdue I mean it's been so long I
was looking at the archives was probably
like episode number four of ILP is where
you were met a long time ago like you
put costed about three o'clock in the
morning to you further thank you for
coming
actually you're in the future right now
in Australia so you're dead so thank you
for coming from the future back to the
past to deal with the lords what you've
been playing votes the lotto numbers
he was king wants a lot but I'd like to
give that to you but I just can't don't
see a life like that dude I'm already
altering my man's life that's enough
good to have you back in so what have
you been playing what games even black
got a little bit of anything really
lately so obviously the I'll start with
the games I'm playing at the moment the
division to anybody who knows me knows
that I was always going to be on the
division to look it's great but a lot of
the issues that I have with the division
one don't exist which is fantastic but
unfortunately it's an airsoft game so
give it time and they'll break it
somehow and Sakura only wanting a little
bit of time into that as well not not as
much as I'd like to because the dark
zone keeps on calling me back yeah
Sakura is a really interesting game from
from software where if you are a Dark
Souls fan you really find yourself
trying to re-educate your your thought
process about how you need to attack
combat in that game is is fun it is it's
dark and dreary and it's a game of of
your death and destruction but there's
so much compassion and it's lovely yeah
absolutely yeah that's good that's good
I'm good that she was still gaming and
rocking and the little one is here
future of the realm with us so we know
if you have to step away it's totally
understandable for a few it's all good
but uh before we start the show I mean
obviously you guys seen a tweet this is
a wow this is a very difficult day for
the Lords we lost our brother Lord
whiskey on last night and um yeah it was
it was really tough to do the show and
but I know this is something that he
would have wanted you know fellow
veteran combat medic some of the best
calves in the business King you know one
of our e3 brothers he tries to go to us
at all the time you know all the events
and um just a good good person you know
I've really miss him I want to send
condolences to his family and this is a
tough day for the Lord so I mean we lost
a good person
so I want to respect him and honor him
today and give it to King you know
addicts they want to say any comforts
for our brother low whiskey you know I
like to start off with you know a lot of
times when somebody passes you know we
we blow Vader on you know there's a good
person II do really wasn't you know you
just said not whiskey whiskey was a very
genuine good soul very good person very
approachable very given like he'll give
you a lot his last known even look at
anything in return he was a Iron Chef
all right hey chef Thanks along with hot
monkey love and know these guys made
sure that we were well fed with premium
food at all times like it really didn't
matter these guys were absolutely there
to you know like help out and the sad
part about it is on just was playing
with him another day he just like got it
in on the division and I was like you
know when I jumped in I was like yo um
you know I'll see you at e3 because I
need my chef fast yeah we were just
playing the business so much because
he's from that era he's from Maryland so
he was probably and he worked there you
know what I mean so we planned the
vision he's like calm this is it's
really it's just like oh okay
so in your head in your head we always
feel like things are always good with
somebody
mm-hmm because we're good and that
doesn't mean it's always bad I've told
people before I've dealt with and I deal
with depression not clinical depression
could be I don't know that I'm soaked to
go
- real get real um like you know help or
whatever but I deal with because I push
on I make sure I put things in my path
to help me get past certain things but
the best thing that you can do is have a
base
listen um us not knowing it growing up
our Saturday's were therapeutic yes
Saturday's were enlightening because we
had family we bonded so whatever we were
missing like in our actual families we
met up as a team as a back fax these
days I don't miss Sunday's like I'm here
like you know and are eager to be here
to be with my brothers to show this love
because we all depend on each other and
we all lean on each other and I mean I
wish you two leaned on me I wish you two
reached out to me but it's not about me
it's about him and I love and I respect
him Lord fireball no man I asked the
whiskey day was it so funny but let
addict speak because I think you got a
chance to meet him what is it III 2017
I'm gonna say when the fireball instead
of habit where he was dubbed Lord
whiskey he golfed an entire what was a
fifth of good for about ten minutes
couldn't find him he went missing we
could not find him so we panicking like
hell he just disappeared off its own in
your strange place with our team member
listen I'm gonna find out he in the
bathroom he locked us up in there
no I don't want y'all to see me like
this
he's like vomited all over the place
don't you think he left that day I was
like okay maybe that wasn't a good idea
Oh young shout-out to Mowgli points who
also knows Lord whisky with the 15
dollar super chat what - Lord salute -
low whiskey sorry for your loss brother
much respect yeah he was our destiny
brother a division brother um like like
addict said I'm sorry to interrupt you
had like we all vote together at first
III you know and just to see the joint
his face because this man truly loved
video games he was so happy just to
finally be a part of it and I'm sorry I
had a good I'll let you finish the story
you were going into yeah it's he was a
good dude man it kind of caught me by
shock when what I was told
yeah absolutely man cried all night you
know still probably gonna crash some
more blood up whiskey salute my brother
you know I'm saying I hope you're
resting we love you you know I'm saying
and I say anybody this goes out to
anybody who is dealing with anything man
like I said don't be don't feel like
you're alone always reach out you know
I'm saying the Lord's are here for that
you know and like a king said community
suffers from a lot of things man and
games bring us together so why God dudes
are beefing about which console and
which platform is better these are the
things that's important you know I'm
saying people are losing lives out here
so that's all I got to say I know when
solve joins and you'll probably say some
more things but uh let's let's get the
show going this is what he would have
wanted you know runs and and uh i'll
peace salutes on my brother man rest in
peace Oh whiskey alright so you know we
got the Four Horsemen of gaming or three
horsemen until uh solve arrives but my
co-host with the co most my brother from
another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the how
of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir doing
pretty good I've been playing a lot of
this sucker okay I like a lot like
what's funny is the Division two came
out and I was all hyped for that and I
still you know really want to get down
in that game but after I started okay I
will say I dropped the game initially
drop it I
did more the drop but I publicly said I
was gonna drop because in the other you
know I've played all the Dark Souls and
you know one thing I didn't like about
them was the the pairing system I always
thought it was gimmicky I never really
thought it was useful
besides certain situation certainly it
but I was okay so I'm played this game
but I'm like it I was talking to you
know Lord your big Matt John I was like
you know what it feels like they done
he's always it feels like they were like
okay AJ don't like parent we got some
for you the whole game is Perry well wow
so now you always I saw your initial
tweet are you over the the Perry
situation no it feels like the pairing
was designed for one V once but most the
times one before gotcha so like one
three or four people coming out like
they really want you to go around
it kills many people as you want before
the smoke starts hmm so that's what they
really want you to do and it took me a
little bit because it's like we were
saying before the podcast started if you
played the Oder games
you really have to rewire your brain to
play it's like that's what I have to say
about From Software's they're one of the
few companies that I know that can build
a foundation or they could build another
house just like you but the inside is
completely different but it feels just
like the other house there's awesome and
it's good to see everybody getting
together with it so that's good that you
plan it and now loving it my technical
lord will be on the way but of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
XS gamer ooh the lord of combat sports
was a man of his convictions that means
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir I'm
gonna do um see that statue back there
now if y'all listening to the king of
the statues you understand that I feel
like you should have that on for some
reason II that it look like something he
would have with the Frog
fraud alert eyes in order I did order
than one of those lights the shipping
says is gonna be here like Monday or
Tuesday look at you it's I mean I did
still it from all right right um but the
thing about it is it can't be broken
um and but that wasn't what I was gonna
unbox this week I was not unboxing this
week is over here um that's it that's
gonna be my first versus series before
we go to pax and so that that's gonna
get up him stuff videoing and editing
this week
but I was playing um division ok play
real hard and division - shout-out to
hot monkey and his boy Black Bart Black
Bart is funny as hell know about those
do some serious animals we was taking
down strongholds like they would paper
tissue because these news is already at
the four tier for coming with 450 gear
and my little twenty five year old self
like breaking leads down and oh whoa
Lina say I have win in one of their
games and I'm tear for my little behind
and it was giving me all the gold drops
for me right oh so they would like they
shed it and it's all for fifty stuff now
apparently in this game which I love
that division has done is this is how it
goes
those first levels to get to 30 that was
just the training mm-hmm so when you hit
30 the game really only thought royalty
yeah right so okay so now un well Tier
one and then you get to wait - - and
then you know you're going up levels as
like destiny like power tears right um
that is such an ingenious formula that
it allows your game to have so much
yeah and it's so much leveling there's
so much things to do they impact this
world well whatever we complained about
the first game yet shut up now
you played that long and I honestly have
to say that Ubisoft is king publishers
and developers it's shin like I can't I
can't front they're like okay they're
not like other other Studios like we
just got a abandon ship they're like now
we go we gonna bring more people and we
gonna fix it oh I mean it it's great now
she's waiting for the first raid I
believe they're gonna knock it out the
part I believe so I'm giving them the
back I have to agree with her on that I
got see that raid but then I gotta grind
to see that right so I got to get on
that when I'm there but that's what I
was playing um III think I play
something else but nothing memorable I
guess yeah I forgot to mention I did
that dream daddy things seem I'll make
sure people know I did that
yo shout out to cat daddy fat stacks up
Adrian who made Lord addict through the
dream daddy challenge don't watch this
whole video king you gotta watch the
first 30 seconds with the intro to the
song of that game and watch Attucks face
so please Atticus on your generator yeah
it's on the gaming addict Channel please
check it out
dream daddy challege Lord addict of men
in his word he did it cat daddy put him
through the fire that if you want to
laugh watch the first 30 seconds and you
erupt in tears I probably should
continue kick that's about it um I don't
know what else I was playing other than
that division that's the only thing
that's like worthy um but I did get the
chance to game but my fellow Lord for
the last time you know and of course we
have the Lord of the cooperative game
experience in gaming into himself the
shinobi Lord Cognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP not only what
you want to hit but what you need to hit
so yeah man I'm not much gaming
obviously with the news that happened
but um like King said I got a chance to
play with my brother in Division two hit
the streets you know of DC and just hear
him tell me all the landmarks and all
the stuff that he was working on and
stuff like that so that was cool I did a
little bit of our destiny to invitation
of the nine um started second row but I
mean literally actually can't even talk
about it my first 10 and 15 minutes into
the game before I had to go to bed
so it's downloaded today is the day that
I actually get to blaze later on tonight
so that's what I'm don't say I don't
want to see you stream that game yeah I
know you want to CP I want to see you so
bad if you're it's not only I still
think because it's your first dark your
first dark souls type game that you're
gonna have a better chance of going cuz
I go I stop I start streaming first
Emma's not played any duh so it's not
nothing like that guys let me tell you
how bad that it was bad for me at first
like I stop streaming the game because I
was holding some yeah that's right I was
like me I I restarted the game three
times mm-hmm cuz I was like man like I
couldn't get the parry system downs but
you know I think since you don't have to
because you literally had to rewire your
brain when you feel like going left or
like no way we gave the student ability
this time we're just gonna grab you when
you try to do that stuff you used to do
yeah listen know everything about it's
like I respect for the franchise and I
know they're great games I just knew the
original ones were not for me and I
never really I just constantly bounces
last night I never really liked the drab
kind of aesthetics and story of the
souls games it just didn't captivate me
but yeah you care about your Saturday I
understand you respected number one
right cuz I don't won't break any
controllers I got enough controllers
here I don't need to be breaking any
more I think it's really broken illegit
replace your controllers are getting
broken I don't need any broken shows
however I am the gaming ninja that
should know me so when I saw feudal
Japan they did a good job on that
let's go at reversal with a grappling
hook and I saw stealth like tenchu then
I'm like okay I'm any and then I watch
the bosses
down the stream and it had a little bit
of a Bushido blade so I play and I'm
like okay I've known what struggle I'm
know I'm probably not gonna last too
long on this but at least I'll give this
one a shot because it's more it speaks
more to me and if you think the thing
with games like this is if you have
patience and you don't get greedy you
didn't have a good time you can win
every time man but that's that's the
problem I'm a ghost story and then I saw
a set from software and that says from
the bushes let me tell you something
okay when when a developer purposely
goes out they set up they set up shop in
a difficult sown listen we care not
about you casual dudes we want you to
suffer
there they are saved and masters of the
a very often you don't don't you always
put the older generations games on a
pedestal and they're all hard like that
no no I don't you guys are always saying
look at this game I play from back in
the day this game I it was hard bad
addict listen I'm gonna tell you this I
always give you your respect when we
played that sitting game it look
beautiful and look beautiful
be about that game and then it taught me
right there five seconds into the game
it taught me I'm not about this game
like a king no money is better money
from software I was like damn it listen
how to get good yes no there's no
getting good there's no easy you got it
are you dumb you can't you can dance
well you can't Lord King is he's not
like some of these people that he just
doesn't like the game so he says the
game's trash no way at least he says
what it looks good it's just not my type
of game I'm gonna watch
Isabella he's acknowledging his
limitations and his gaming was in them I
have a problem with punishment like like
what I thought I jumped off a cliff on
accident and it didn't penalize me an
order Dark Souls any of those Dark Souls
games you fall off a cliff its gg you
have to start over back from the last
checkpoint
yes back up on this one with like 10%
less hell and it's like oh you don't die
you just lose a little bit health I was
like that's not cool I want to die if I
follow up now this is you see this they
taught you how to like it I don't want
to be taught how to like abuse what I'll
do is I'm gonna watch people screams
like I watched kids yesterday I was like
oh I was part of that 8000 crew don't
want to see him bashes facing ever
though there is 800 people watching that
full play him bustled up controllers I
said there it is there it is that's
exactly look it really isn't that hard
if like I said before if you've got
patience and you don't get greedy who
has patience you see this this is green
this is no that's not that game is
definitely not the mentality that you
needed these kind of games is okay to
hitch is enough not me like I get myself
killed so many times but okay I got two
I think I could sleep Forbes then they
just slightly okay maybe you gotta learn
the pattern and once you learn the
pattern you got a secret in the pattern
if you don't stick within the pattern
you're gonna have a bad time of things
okay the only openings of attack I had
is was just a grappling hook attack
that's literally all I could find an
opening would and i sat with that dude
for almost an hour fighting him
that one new remember cog me and I told
you my son and I watch attic play that
game on PlayStation and my son was
enamored with his skill that's it then
you know that point where you Michael
Jordan and somebody looking at LeBron
and your son is looking at LeBron your
son is like oh LeBron is like shut up
LeBron a nice does he shut up that's the
day I had to bend the knee to him when
my son was like so now we get the lower
the laws have been playing and even
though later Bella she's been a few
times check I hope eaten before and I
hope you know but so well for spectively
but she wasn't around for the debut of
IOP top 5 so lady Bella I need your top
video games or franchises of all time no
pressure of all time okay so obviously
Zelda Ocarina of Time is always okay fun
15 genes [ __ ] I don't mind 15 I was just
disappointed what we supporting it we
don't even have enough we don't even
have enough time for that we could talk
about that after the podcast 1313 was
utter utter back like it was
I couldn't 30 is the only final fantasy
about never be lady Bella final fantasy
15 that's on your list we got it Zelda
give me 300 give me four more Meenakshi
thing look I'm gonna put horizon zero
dawn up I may just because of the depth
of the storytelling in that game it the
floor just continued you get dropped out
from underneath you as you play through
that and realized the depth of the law
and the the history that they had
created because we had a they hit that
out of the park yeah I mean there were
there were many aspects so that came
like but I would put that up there
purely because of how they basically
taught the gaming industry how to tell a
story again it was it was epic who rises
it all right so we got Zelda a big list
I love it Final Fantasy 15 so we need
two more again these are franchises that
are important to you hmm you know we did
just discuss Dark Souls but I'm gonna
put that up there because that's that is
a game changer it's all franchise that
that yeah that franchise taught me how
to be a better gamer knowing that the
importance of checking every corner and
not not taking anything for granted
okay I think Loki I really think you're
going at me but I'm not that good so
angle we're by day remember remember
Bella look at his background
everything's about him no no only in my
world that's a really difficult on the
spot one maybe but time for reflection
you can really think about it change
your life had a special place in your
heart for just you somebody kept stop
putting in gears Bella cares Bella no I
you know what case this is a great
franchise but it's not really really
like Khalid 80
circle what then you really enjoy
apology at one point like all what some
reason I felt like the last time she was
on ILP we argued about one game it is
and here's the thing about ecology I
actually grew up and became an adult and
you know moved on and I matured my game
preferences
learn how to play something with a
little bit of depth and meaning instead
of just running around like an
adrenaline junkie shooting people you
know how you to do no no no I completely
I'm on Bella's side right okay you guys
get all the meteor for scrubs one
something to change your language just
just hey just do something that you like
there won't be a personal favorite one
slot
it was drained that mcclift once live
all the video games that I played my
wife I've got one slot left to fill
that's a really difficult task a place
hold it and when you come back you can
always change I always give the options
still I guess that come on I expect
better from you bout this
you got so many games or attack come on
so just pick one Superman game for the
n64 there you go destiny that's it we
picked it around at the moment as was
you know what for the interest of
putting something on this let's go with
this inning because that's where I met
the love of my wife that game has a
special place in my heart bringing
people together because there you go
where you come back again if we realize
there is no problem so we gonna get into
last week's poll and start the show last
week poll results are in and the people
have spoken to the question with the
latest rumors regarding Google's
potential upcoming console announcement
at GDC how seriously do you take Google
as a threat in the next-generation
console wars the winner at 42% in a
fairly close three-way ILP vote is
the I'm sold Google's partners Bank and
aggressiveness automatically make them a
threat coming in at second very close
where our shadow voters at 32% was that
I don't care
okay Google and Google Plus gotta get
out the bushes first group thank you
it in last place at 26% was the I'm not
so project stream and Google will not
win without games thanks to all the
lords who participated in last week's
poll actually I see mods gaming in the
building in the building sir hey guys
what's up it's nice to be back nice to
be liked I'll bring it to you and Bell
Oh what do you guys feel about it just
do you agree with the poll that people
feel that um that Google will be a
threat
yeah much yeah I should go for well I
mean well potentially because like I
think that Google is kind of aiming at a
bit different consumer base because
basically like I don't think that I mean
like you know hardcore gamers or people
who are kind of good used to like
playing on a local hardware just going
to throw out all their I know consoles
and PC to the bushes and so but the
thing is like I think that's you know
all these and and that's not only about
Google all these streaming services will
be aimed at completely different you
know people yeah demographics of course
different people like if I look at my
son for example he's like six years old
I mean he grew up with you know not
necessarily playing games I'm like he's
growing up actually still not with like
you know consoles and stuff you know
he's he's basically using he's a tablet
all the time right hmm and you know
guess what's going to happen when
Google's going to launch this no
streaming service
when and listen you know they are there
they've got to Google
they've got YouTube on their side like
listen you know the mah mah mah that's
gonna be the first time I know you about
to go it I can hear you go going yeah
okay so all I want to say that you know
if you know think about the fact that
they've got you took on their site and
also they are the biggest search engine
in world or in the world so yeah it will
be a friend all right so you feel like
that lady Bella do you agree with the
poll that Google should be considered a
threat well my knee-jerk reaction to the
whole thing is the more the merrier
you know what have we got to lose from
there being more competition in the
market and what that competition creates
lower prices creates better services etc
etc the only problem that I have with it
all is how many subscriptions do I have
to be signed up for to make sure that
I'm getting all my games I don't need
you know I mean at the end of the day
I'd probably just go look good and say
well that's great but are you giving me
the value that the game pastors give me
because if you can remove all value no
cost interested I hate valid valid
points we gotta get into it I was hoping
sake get it yeah we saw fit build it
slow oh no five you hear me okay baby
quiet Stovall Slavs in the building bro
first off man thank you guys you could
make it and I know like I said we
briefly said some things for whiskey I
don't know if you wanted to say anything
real quick before you started and then
we get into the show
yeah absolutely uh first off what's up
mods what's up Bela
good to see you guys yeah honestly the
once [ __ ] told me it it really it
destroyed me man because we we all know
what this community means to all of us
and and for a lot of us it's a refuge it
really is from from whatever our
realities are on a day-to-day basis and
whiskey man I I got to meet him at e3
2016 it was the only time I got to meet
him
that's all right in KY Basu and I I
think we were that was the year that not
all of us got into able to get into to
fan fest correct oh yeah so whiskey was
walking around with us you know showing
us the Rope showing us stuff in the
convention center so I what I got from
him was that he was a very genuine
person like a very kind dude always
willing to help always a smile on his
face loved being there like that was
being at III was like that he looked
every instant every moment of it and of
course I'm sure somebody told the
fireball story
yeah I mean that was that was something
else so everybody's like where's whisky
where's Dave oh my lord and then oh man
I don't even want to talk about how that
lobby bathroom but um I mean we're gonna
miss you bro I wish you were here and be
honest man I just just a a message on
his behalf to everyone in the community
do not ever ever keep anything to
yourself all jokes aside everything that
we talked about we laugh we joke console
war stuff that means nothing nothing
guys we're all here for each other we
all love the same thing facts and I know
this anytime anybody puts anything up on
Twitter that that's a real-world issue
that they have a problem people flock
with with with with kind words and and
and so I know that all that you know
that supporter I love exist in this
community products so if you're ever
feeling like you're alone you never are
you absolutely never are and I just I
just really wish man I just really wish
we could have done more man but I wish
you were here whiskey man rest in peace
brother man Capri's brother rest in
peace brother cut great words cuts off
you know yeah I cried and we cross the
wall man like I said we missed some bro
we definitely miss him
so look let's get the show going cuz
this is what he would have wanted gawrsh
he's chewing into us every Sunday was in
that chat
those game with a yeah I mean that he
that's that's one thing hey you know you
know how we are and I'm a Thai person if
carve out is for you if King Mouse is
for you if Kai box is for your family I
don't there's no second thinking there's
no thought your family that's it that's
it um and it's just it's just a
heartbroken today it's not the way to
put it
you know doubt alright let's celebrate
some life and have some fun you know
what do you want so we got to pull out
the way solve you're actually right in
time because I was gonna lead off your
topic oh yeah you're right on service so
um obviously the gaming news has been
shaken as a lesson new a new challenger
has appeared you saw what's going on
with this Stadium
what's going on bro right so yeah this
past week Google finally unveiled their
vision for the future of video games and
and project stream is now Google Stadium
and for all second but before I get into
that how everyone went against us pull
the BS and tell you to cam yeah they
show the controller that's odd with what
I did
I said don't fight me yeah I appreciate
that King cuz there was no official been
Denis we just he said there would be no
count he said there would be no console
I did say it was a dick man you almost
had it man you switch to the losing team
at the last that you gave those this is
gonna be the best Me's you ever lost
today I'm spawn of this defeated me I
don't like this no I know I really feel
like it was me and King versus you two
like I remember thinking like we were
split down the middle I thought for sure
they would have a console he's right
he's dated they didn't that's a browse
me all right so let's get it to yes so
stadia is basically an evolution of the
beta they have a project stream it is an
online gaming service there's sort of
leverages the Google space so I'm excuse
me the the YouTube space to sort of
integrate streaming and gaming into sort
of this one this one thing on the one
umbrella and they touted some crazy
numbers they said at the core the Google
instance which is a fabulous name as a
blade a stadia instance is about ten
point seven teraflops of graphical power
basically outpacing the Xbox one X I
know I know basically outpacing look
everything and
and together like if you put them so I
just want you to stop I've never seen
King so absolutely
indignant with used to accept this as a
reality I really I've never seen on the
defensive like this no I'm gonna show
you what it is though well you damn I'm
so happy Majesty I'm so happy - jay-z
from Poland is up in the building
because we about the chakras podcast to
July see there's a lot of you guys is
out there sleepwalking with the zombie
face and we're about to wake you behind
I don't know higher thoughts of it have
evolved since the announced but I know
it be announced beyond that um yeah so
the service is set to launch later on
this year in the u.s. most of the UK and
most big markets and there's a lot of
questions behind it because they're
touting a lot of power they're talking
about at launch in ideal situation is
the HDR capabilities which is a huge
leap over anybody who was in that beta
everybody in this chat everybody just
want everybody in the chat she noticed I
want everybody to chat to notice how
antsy King is know what happened last
week everybody's sorry all right you
know what to do that let's let King blow
vape please thank you so much so
everybody strapped down got a chance to
watch that crap that was on TV right now
I want to shout out put your hands up
everybody to fell asleep all right well
I had to rewatch that crap with the
legitimacy to it so what they did was
they picked this dude right cuz he goes
around and he does his little Smurf
tactics at different um companies so he
goes from so oh you heard the dude on
stage say I know nothing about games
that was that was that was a straight-up
why are you here but this guy knows the
difference between an RPG an MPC stage
and let's do with the great clown shoes
come out here I feel like the shoes he
was wearing is in relevant to the
information destroy you Adam there was a
distraction my friend let me tell you
how we do it in New York I can shine a
detour no I'm gonna tell you right now
he D told you he told you he was doing
the magic trick the whole time now one
time did you see a game now one time did
you hear any real specs they gave you
specs of the server but I didn't going
to you that's gonna be divided between
everybody
oh so I'll let you sitting there talk
about you might get us you might get a
game that is has less power than the
switch oh my
not necessary for you to have ten
teraflops in a certain game right so you
will get exactly what you're allocated
for that game all right so you don't
have any hardware so there's nothing to
nail that down they're gonna start
nailing down latency they're gonna start
nailing down stuff but the first way to
trick your behind into something is to
not give you price not to give you date
not to give you games they actually
showed you absolutely nothing with a
fried rail with the two dollars in which
they said get them tired of people
falling for does the banana in the
tailpipe you fell for a banana in the
tailpipe yo guys out here talking is
crippling o'mike result is in trouble
yo my topic is going to directly
challenge that conversation hmm but also
now RT a legitimate threat yes they are
okay they would give you a legitimate
threat before them we had online mini
and sovereign played online a good time
with it it fell off because it had
different issues with it that we worried
we were new to the streaming thing all
right it's I'm not telling people that
this is not real I'm telling you it's
fake in a sense that is going to do
exactly what they are saying initially
if you looked at the sign it says up to
4k 4k okay but then also what happens
now which your whole dependency on your
megabits in your in your in your arm
your connection go true right so we're
gonna have to get into the price format
they're not gonna tell you price because
they don't want to tell you fifty nine
ninety-five a month but if they if they
start charging you on a per game basis
they already in the bushes thing I don't
I don't even think honestly
I don't think that's in in the talking's
over there that would be but how am I
don't stand for something you fool go
for anything
let's go around right now how much do
you think the subscription base would be
like if you were to put a few our
betting man and and you know gun to the
head how much would you say they were
charged a month I don't know let me get
15 yeah let's get let's get Bella and
then let's get mods Bella the Google
stadia announcement did you get a chance
to watch it and everything that was
revealed yeah I obviously got myself up
to date on what's going on with it and
frankly if you come at me with hey we've
got 4k 60fps you're not impressing me
I'm like you know that isn't that isn't
anything that you can use as a to
impress people to go you know well have
you got 4k and 60fps and and teraflops
teraflops was a huge thing about four
years ago when Microsoft starts throwing
the word around back then carrot box
meant something right now it's it's a
gimmick word so I I I'm not gonna get
worked up about it I don't need high
blood pressure - I'm firing the me I
think you know what it's it's another
service let's see what you can do it's
gonna bring up comments like the same
it's gonna bring more competition to the
market so be it
shout out to dizzy with the final a
super chair dizzy
fight the good fight against the fools
it just you know what it is and honestly
like a lot of the push back on this it
sounds like a bunch of scared old men
honestly no no no and no insults any but
that's what it sounds like hear what
you're saying sir but I also want you to
remember we have been down this road
together together no King that was a
decade ago and this is what I'm telling
you this is why I'm telling you we're
able to see with our clear eyes bro
we still got 20 20s so I want you to put
these pupils to work and I want you to
look at it I want you to strip it away
not what you want it to be
what it is right I want you to be honest
from me did you really take away from
that what I just finished saying that in
that beta that it got nowhere near any
4k 60 and obviously they said they
capped it right it was the point of it
wasn't to do that right but my thing is
this where the point in media where
anything you say if you're lying it
comes back to you at the drop of a hat
this there's no big turnaround where
people have to figure out if you're
lying if you're lying or even if you
come off the least bit suspect the
Internet's gonna jump on you right so my
thing is your Google your coming out
here you're making all of these these
statements they have to be true and it
can't all be and then everybody's
getting in on this at the same time it
can't all be wrong I asked you one
question
actually one question what the hell did
you really take from this I didn't ask
you what you thought what did this is
your credit card now right your credit
card is up this is it
so they said at the end of this show if
they told you at the end of the show do
you had this all right get Emily now
right great are you putting your credit
card on the table right now but I don't
know anything without good
let's get full disclosure right because
all right myself enough credit you
actually were in the project stream beta
less
period slash like I said my experience
was nowhere near any 4k 60 and they
maxed it they maxed it at 1080 60 and I
and in ideal situations late at night or
early in the morning and I hit that in
the middle of the day I'd get less than
that I get worried oh just a lot of
people on and hey is it Eliza hello a
lot more people on so like I said like
the fact it really did surprise me when
they said yeah we're gonna hit 4k 60
now you know the way algorithms work
yeah they're constantly tweaking them
they're constantly improving them my
thing is if you make a statement like
that and and you know you can't get
anywhere near that that can fold your
okay you how low did it get for you as
far as the resolution that's what yours
are what's the resolution I think it's a
state of 1080 pretty much the entire
time except when they work there were
moments when it be artifact thing and it
blur out then it come right back right
so about what phrase would you get would
you get will be getting it yet it would
be thick to in as low as points like 10
80 30 just out of curiosity what kind of
internet connection you have what's the
connection you tell us he got the best I
have 300 megabits up and down well like
your average person ain't gonna have
that kind of internet a lot of time we
get moths so I you saw that you saw the
whole stadium reveal you know I'm saying
it's - like where's what's your take on
and what you feel the impressions on it
I think
mads I think that their demographic
they're targeting they're talking to
that everyday call of duty person I
don't think call of duty is really gonna
be key issue but I think they're
targeting people who play Madden every
year people who play 2k every year like
they're trying to eat that up you know
they're gonna probably market this is
you don't have to buy a console next-gen
all you have to do is just get on our
service and play the two games you play
a year mm-hmm I think that you would've
spend on an Xbox is gonna be trapped
down automatically off the rip on that
card when you put it in because you
didn't pay for console so give us the
$500 towards these games that's exactly
what's gonna happen for what you think
description and cost of entry is gonna
be $9 a month
Wow cuz they just told you you can watch
a YouTube video and click on it play now
wait I feel like that's absurd I feel
like that is that that's unrealistic
well I why is that unrealistic guys are
$60 a month first
oh yeah the money yeah I thought you
meant that the clicking on the video
part No
that's unrealistic call it a dick he
said Call of Duty with that Lacey how is
gonna be possible at it I just don't
think moment now you that's what I said
I don't think that's gonna be something
people are gonna get the subscription
service that's why I went to Madden 2k
so you talk about those type of games as
a player when I brought up Call of Duty
it was just to give you know the biggest
casual games out there
let me on let me get Lord mods in here
well as the the technical game II what
did you feel about a stadia spreadin
tation okay well obviously we haven't
seen any games and stuff on on the stage
apart from I mean we know that the only
two has been confirmed so far so that
was a disappointing thing but from
technical point of view I was I would
say that it was pretty interesting show
right because like I get that people
find it boring because as I said like
for most gamers
games right what really matters right
and there was no games with there really
apart from a couple of technical demos
which doesn't tell you much to be honest
with you so I I actually like my purse I
personally I found it like pretty
interesting and obviously even I even
wrote the bloody article about the you
know CDR council being more powerful
than Xbox one X right if we write that
article sir
at Lords of gaming but they didn't
really show any like any did they show
any multiplayer games at all
demonstrated on the turtle right we're
talking about it telling me you know and
I don't think they really showed any
like on-screen action either side the
Fonzarelli with the $2 suit which at
some of y'all on that google dust like
you're the one on the Google does
Nani's Pierpont is the promise of new
games on the ready for nothing to see
even even even game pass is not telling
you date and day these games is coming
out so if you're watching YouTube
because these news want to use they
they're trying to take over twitch they
want to they want to push twitch to the
side they want to push mixer to the side
they want you to primarily gain upload
and clicking they want you to do
everything on one hub they want you to
be your one-stop media sent to you they
want you to be your own your best
stadium you understand everybody they
can line up and you can have people
that's on your stream line up and you
know action - this feels like um how
when Xbox got into the game business
like computer people are making a gaming
console now get out of here you're not
doing that in the tailpipe and I'm
telling you the price wise this is where
the BS when he said no price no even
though ass track price then no games
they stay telling you they gave you
showed you outside of a car with no
engine no wheels they said you can
purchase this and when you ready next
year you understand we let you know
really what's going on inside of this
you know what let me be a devil's
advocate here because like I I get to I
I must give them today I mean I must
give it to them because like I mean GDC
is not really an America where he talked
about games
gaudí about yeah and they pay and they
did they did say like shortly after the
event that they will be showing games
and talking about above the whole you
know service pricing and stuff shortly I
mean like in they said summer of this
year so I mean III know pretty much
right so I think that GDC wasn't really
the place to because that's why they
they focus so much on the technical
aspects demos and stuff right you know
this reminds me of like PlayStation 4
you know first announcement without any
specifics was CERN it was Ernie exactly
I mean James say then anything we had
with digital 400 e we revealed that the
Scorpio it was them talking about all
the teraflops and the technical
performance but no games so again let me
children his day
oh I'll scroll overhead Lord leader
filumena successfully imitated both
Microsoft and Sony executive positions
overseers grow hopefully the secret
documents decay is all cloudy for Google
Stadium all hail fear luminous our
favorite Scroll in gaming all jokes
aside look man from I thought from all
the tech perspective like well it was
super impressive from just a technical
stamp right no downloads full YouTube
integration with the streaming community
crowd play allows you to queue up in the
same instance to play against your
favorite streamer it's talking about
cross playing cross progression I Loki
didn't like the state share thing or the
Google assistant that helped me Howard
button they got going on where you could
kind of jump in someone's game and help
them out or whatever that's a little too
much for me but the scalable cloud
compute tech they talk about you know 4k
60 hope with HDR by launch 2019 release
before X cloud so that was a little wild
moment cuz I didn't think they'd jump
out the gate that hard and fast now for
the game's part I get it King you know
say like they did it was nothing really
to show besides the doom eternal and
Assassin's Creed but like they do in
okay get at it I do feel like that they
should have demonstrated more different
variety of games I agree
but we got to remember like this is GDC
it is to demonstrate that service and if
you're not demonstrating that service
with the type of games that you'd be
playing on that service like I don't
really care about their exclusive games
obviously you're not gonna now stuff
like that Achebe's it right but I do
know like they should thoroughly show
you how the service would work you've
ever launched great auto show - they
show the Assassin's Creed Odyssey and I
showed the module maternal now look I
get it
playable and was playable on the thing
is Game Developers Conference if you
come in here expecting game
in trailers to be revealed you gonna be
disappointed like this is more to get
the devs in tune with the functionality
and potential in the tech now the name
and logo the stadium's a little weird I
wasn't really feeling that part but I
thought the conversate that the cough
the conference from a pure presentation
standpoint was strong that's all I'm
saying well my presentation is gonna
appeal they look like they're trying to
appeal to the mobile market or them
casual gamers who never gonna invest in
a traditional console now this is where
I agree with King so many questions
unanswered will it really work right so
far the testing has been a mixed bag you
know I'm saying digital foundry has said
that they if they play today tested it
the luck the latency is rivaling that of
a local xbox 1x you know I'm saying but
then I saw some footage of people
playing dual maternal and it looks us it
looks us with the fast twitch it didn't
it didn't move quick and I'm saying
what's the cost
it's like kings in is it subscription
base how do they address people with
Dana cabs you know I'm saying are they
gonna be doing ISP partition would you
feel like that's something like GDC like
rice would be an appropriate thing to
talk about oh I can't sit under like
that's the biggest key like like ADC is
mainly just used to demonstrate what
that service does not what it costs not
what's on it right just to show you this
and what it can do that that's why I
left it alone and then they did he did
have an interview with on Jason Schreyer
Phil Harrison didn't have interest with
Jason Schreyer from kotaku and they kept
saying summer summer summer which I'm
gonna gree with mine I'm gonna film it
that is important right but here's the
thing it's got so many questions right
we got you know their Google Fiber it's
not gonna be able to we have no issue
with neutrality you know we got by
joining arises and they plan on a
multiple car happen I'm sorry my fault
yeah okay there we go go can you hear me
now better better all right we got all
that going on then the main important
thing is the Google track record like
will they stick with it if it go left
they've got a notorious history
sometimes over things don't pop off
they're out so to me the way I look at
is this it's either gonna be the Steven
extreme equivalent of the Dreamcast
we're there to pioneer they get out gig
first but then unfortunately phase out
or they go be like the xbox 360's
treatment where they got the one year
head start
they beat X crowd to the punch at the
wrong game you know I'm saying but again
it's still more questions exclusive
games we know they got Jade Raymond and
their studio how far along are these
games so that's why I got I'm in the
middle with both you guys I'm willing to
see I want to see the tech I think
competition is good I grew a Bella but
at the same time there's still a lot of
questions here before I just crown it as
okay this is what it is you know I'm
saying but I'm gonna give it back to
Bella as far as like not as far as now
what the competition is
I got to go ahead and take off though
you guys appreciate everyone come on
talk to you guys later
so again you know I gotta see I just
want to talk about when Bell as far as
now the competition aspect with
Microsoft and you know do you think this
is good in general for Microsoft that
they're in this space does this force
Microsoft's hands to kind of step up a
little bit I don't think it's
unfortunate do anything really I mean
the powerhouse industry they'll always
do what they wanted to do and I don't
think anyone but Sony is kind of ever do
anything to force them to have to change
what they're doing the service that
they're providing the thing I would be
interested to hear you particularly know
after seeing just how hot all of this
got King's blood thermos it is gonna
change your life so significantly and it
don't get you so upset
whoa well okay mmm really I'm purchasing
it disclosable oh I'm fighting for the
little guy I'm mad I don't represent the
little guy okay but all right I want
y'all to understand that part I don't
represent you guys that's sitting there
talking about no I don't represent you I
wrote that the Letus all right this is
targeted to me if they sell $59 a month
in every new game that came out was
playable off the rip
yes who's paying $59 s who's not it's
not gonna bother me I got fiber optics
so another that stuff that you're
talking about is actually gonna bother
me this is not for me this is my fight
is for you
where they showed you to banana in the
tailpipe now what I'm talking about when
i when i get all aunty and all upset is
IC fro turi and i'm gonna call it out if
Sony does it if Microsoft does I told
you Microsoft showed you uh uh their
Google X joint and and that wasn't
really me I don't care what you said um
it wasn't real it was a control
situation and I don't believe that was
real other people saying it is oh well
wells you're gonna say Oh King you know
you're calling out Google calling
Microsoft and I call on Sony and I call
out Nintendo daily all right I I
employed them they work for me I
purchase stuff and Ikes and if they if
any one of those dudes do not produce in
a fashion that I want them to produce
and guess who's fired and I got a new
hire coming in I'm hiring Google to see
what y'all talking about now I don't
understand how people gonna get in an up
run you said this is not the the area
where you gonna show games right they
said one studio if Microsoft for the
stepped up and said we got one studio
these news would have blew the internet
up if you do the Microsoft steps up
there with no games
oh they blow the internet if Microsoft
steps up there with no price they blow
the internet up my thing is keep that
same damn energy you frauds mmm he's the
kind of said the same thing recently
because he said well Microsoft kind of
jumped out the gate first with the DRM
and then oh all basically they're not
given any option right like what Google
is and it would Microsoft even those
well it was six years ago whatever it
was you know I'm saying they got kind of
crucified for that so I mean was it a
good thing that you just feel Microsoft
was just so ahead and it's not the same
energy this is what I'm saying
Microsoft stepped on save there's
talking TV TV TV TV crap right you guys
got all your panties tore up and ripped
up for a bunch right you remember when
they said your Xbox was gonna be on all
the time all the time now you know what
if y'all would have sat then allowed
them to push all in the direction that
we were going in anyway we had already
had Google stadia already hmm but now
they have to revise things to smooth it
over for you guys to just
a little legal to get you nice and ready
to go into the new millennium
but then Google you're just ready young
judges don't like certain things anybody
else says it no more adapt to go that
way I just told you they showed you
absolutely nothing keep the same damn
energy that you had over there over here
so I'm going to show you some games and
show you price and they show you stuff
like that then you champion it some
champion something and they didn't show
you anything controller of an Xbox and a
PlayStation controller but my focus now
it isn't so much the games I'm focusing
on the impact is gonna have on gaming as
a whole I'm looking at the tech the tech
is what to me is what's most disruptive
right gaming the games are gonna be
there or not there in whatever but the
the fact that they're leaning so heavily
onto it there's no way it's not the
initiation of a paradigm shift let's go
wait not let me go through and that's
the thing that it's it's just it's the
fact that the tech is definitely moving
in that direction and there's no
stopping that there's a shout out to
bring them around with a $2.00 super
chair I want to make one thing clear to
is like look let's be clear like we
don't know for a fact if this gonna work
right we until we get it in our hands
until there's real-life testing until
every one with every different internet
situation and data cap and all that gets
it in their hand then we can judge we
can't just so I'm in the Midwest my
thing is let's just see what happens
when we get in time with Bella in that
respect but Fonz I gotta come at you
because you go hard in the chat no one's
championing anything my thing is I'm not
quick to dismiss something until I tried
like a lot of people I'm seeing it's
like oh it's definitely not gonna work
it's definitely definitely I'm not on
that type of time you know saying so my
thing is let's get it on our hands let's
see it lets see what realistically how
they deal with people with data captured
all these problems cuz there are no
questions and I feel you fun in a sense
that yo I'm you know there's still a lot
of issues that we don't know how they're
gonna tackle I will say this in
reference to Microsoft is that what King
is saying is true in this respect and
the fact that marks
was so ahead right of the game in terms
of the whole DRM and all that stuff they
look eventually we got there the thing I
notice now and look at X cloud it seems
that they're taking the opposite
approach right now 2019 it's kind of
like we're gonna bring in the beta trial
first right we're gonna get people
accustomed to X cloud and stuff like
that we saw Phil's statement in
reference to stadia and he was kind of
saying look he gave him validation for
his streaming future in his vision
PlayStation in their credit they were
ahead they would they were trying this
earlier obviously less tech and I'll get
into that later and I'm saying so what
King is saying is true like the industry
is going this way and again option only
thing that stadia is not giving it an
option stadia saying yo this is what it
is right also yeah guys in that preview
tower chat that we have in the
background right so this day these dudes
was ripping me a new one I wonder I want
y'all to know something because I'm
calling these dudes on the carpet for
this they was ripping me in knowing it
was going to film Dominus know Phil
minimis luminous mister light break the
helmet fakes field scroll Phil right and
I told them I said rap battle rule
straight up off the RIP y'all for my
belief of my goood today all right rap
battle rules my boy got 24 hours to
respond at it and let me tell you
something my boy responded with buckshot
straight for the face he showed you what
the next day what's coming out on game
pass and then he reached out he lined
the troops up you want me to split the
bars you're miserable
let's do bars please l jumped in the
booth he saw the steady announcement he
said he just wrapped up he said today we
saw a big tech competitor into the game
market and framed the ingredients
between content community and cloud he
said it was no big surprises you know
say yeah it's just that he's like God he
already knew you don't saying but he
said I want to get back to us he said
there's a really good work to get us
into position and we're poised to
compete for two billion gamers across
the planet
Google went big today and we have a
couple of months so III until we go get
big so he says we have to stay agile
continue to build with our customer at
the centre we have the content community
clout and strategy and as I've been
saying for
it's all about execution this is even
more true today
energizing times Lord Phil King David's
only begotten Savior in terms what all
right Raymond terms said just like this
you say yeah they got guns
I know y'all see that we got guns too
every last one of you guys will be able
to bust back at e3 don't you worry about
those boobs what we saw was absolutely
nothing and we will destroy them come
June why was it nothing that's what I
heard when I show you what he did and
what a boss does what a boss what a boss
does when he sees his side do some guru
and what a boy i'ma show you what a
basta the gaming community does every
time you can planning about your food
before it to even hit the table there
you go there you go I just don't see
like I I don't see why people just can't
be more optimistic from the rib
everybody just negative me the junk and
it's like I'll tell you why because like
you know shortly after shortly after the
the whole presentation I was like I
actually sent a tweet and they were like
basically asking so what the hell the
fun boys are going to fight for if
there's not going to be any plastic
anymore because that's what it's all
about like it's always been about like
oh this is my black box and it's the
best no this is my black box and this
isn't it
and you know the problem is that well
with with with streaming it's like it's
everybody this box right and you know so
you know like it's not finna box right
seriously III today I made an coolest
edia unboxing video right I've put my
all all my mobile devices and everything
I bug them I want to play on that you
want to play that the problem and you
know I mean some people didn't catch the
joke and unfortunately but you know I
mean the thing is like why I don't think
that it actually bothers me much because
like it's just assuming device you don't
have to buy any hardware to actually use
it and like even if very very pricey but
like $15 $20 25 imeem you know I will go
and check it out if it works and if has
any interesting games I'll just use it
if if they if they will keep pushing
more content I may use it more right but
like from my perspective I'm more like a
local hardware guy right and you know
that's not going to change for me
anytime soon and that's why I kind of
like I I pre I I prefer like Sony and
Microsoft approach to it like you know
that's an option right and but at the
end of the day I like you know Google
studia is just like an option to me
right and I mean it may be a threat to
like Microsoft and Sony and Nintendo at
some point in the future not like day
one because I don't see that happening
it will take time to for some people to
actually change they're kind of like I
don't know gaming habits if I can call
it but like you know Google CDI another
streaming services may not be
necessarily for us right you know dudes
that kind of got used to like you know
you know playing on a local hardware and
like talking about graphics and the
image quality and the big best quality
pixels right because that's what we're
going to be talking about when streaming
these games because let's face it
everything is compressed and last last
word on the hall
data captured copses you go for a lot of
people talk about I mean I'm not sure if
my if my internet is good but I actually
watched an interesting video of our guy
who actually took part in the beta test
and if he said that you know he's got
like a hundred megabits up and down like
Internet and stuff right and you know he
was basically getting the same just like
he you know you know he was basically
getting all kinds of different results
like sometimes it was 720p sometimes it
was thirty and stuff and when when the
actual stream actually was downgraded
the quality of stream was now grain they
downgraded he immediately tested the his
collection his internet speeds
everything was fine on his end so that
tells me that there may be also some
hiccups on the Google servers site so it
may not be only your internet dependent
right so Google it was specific about
that too they said that your connection
to their servers is direct I meaning
that it's never actually on the open
Internet it is there it sounds nice what
they actually telling you is that
because Internet is basically our bunch
of routers right and different data
centers so the the only thing what they
actually saying is that okay so you will
have you know that the the connection is
going to be basically from like you know
thus as they said direct but it's still
going to be going over the same things
but just but the actual yeah yeah date
data is not going to be go going over
that these 20 routers but it will just
basically be direct right so like just
like DPN something like that basically
mm-hmm listen I just want to say one
last point and we move on is that all in
reference to the whole competition
aspect and you know listen at the end of
the day as the hard core we are right
this may not be for us like at the end
of the day we are used to you know that
that ultimate response you know without
any type of latency even if like you
said able to nail is knock this thing
out to par you know I'm saying but we
have to be cognizant I want
shadow on braaap is an attack forte and
those guys at a basement radio arcade
podcast they had a great podcast talking
about it and it says that we got to be
Congress at that this may not be for us
y'all like you know say in this mobile
generation in this fortnight generation
in like like you said mods you know I'm
you know the kids are just jumping on
playing on their tablet they don't touch
consoles you know I'm saying again if
this thing is successful it's a big if
we have to see you know I'm saying but
if that ease of use no downloads and
people can just jump on a browser and
jump on a phone or whatever whatever
this may appeal to some you know I'm
saying by the end of the day are still
thinking for a reference to Microsoft I
like the fact that for us as a gamer
it's an option and they still got the
game pass advantage you know I'm saying
whereas Google's all-or-nothing approach
might backfire so I want to see what
Microsoft does with that we know we got
the public beta I like what Phil said in
reference to it this is definitely
coming but again for those of you who do
not like this future go do not buy it
support your hardware consoles and
that's it and you're fine but to see
shot the father.the to our super check
hard core doesn't detect tomorrow you're
right hard core doesn't dictate the
market and casuals do but the end of the
day Microsoft right now is providing you
an option stadia is not if the hard core
does not like the fact that they don't
have that option
don't buy stadium which a wallet end of
case that's it
and if they say yes I think if gamers
what we should focus on with all of all
of these people coming out only these
companies coming out with streaming
services is honestly what does it mean
for the future of gaming in terms of
archiving what does it mean if Google up
and leaves and it's not successful or
not successful in their eyes and they
walk away everything that they brought
to the table what do like what state do
they leave gaming in at that point right
the archiving thing is a big thing
because as I think
gaming in general has been very bad
about preserving its history what do you
do with what the platform that's online
only what happens then once that goes
offline those games are gone
and if they do at some point have a
significant exclusive portfolio what
happens to those games that's the stuff
that you need to think to me is more
worrisome I like cog said everything
else is just an option and that be
thankful that we do have options song
look let's get into it we could go all
day let's get to the second part which
is Kingsport which is the effect right
so King I know you want to touch on that
in reference to some news and reference
to stocks did you want to get into that
game yes sir yes because Sons I saw it
pop up like the day after Sony and
Nintendo stocks took a tumble Microsoft
stocks say the same and my question to
the panel is what did they think about
that if they cared at all about the
situation is it a cause and effect is an
inny jerk reaction to what they saw or
is it our impending doom towards those
two companies because that their
strategy is lacking going towards the
future mmm let's start with a Bella
Bella what do you feel like obviously
the news came out that a little bit of
stock droppage went on the Stadion news
came announced it looked like it
affected short-term actually Nintendo
and Sony so on yeah it looks like they
dropped as much as 4.6 percent and sony
declined 4.5 percent Wednesday when both
the the news was was drop so do you look
into this do you think this is anything
else concerned as far as their streaming
future or what do you take from it well
money my sense this is I don't have
shares in either those companies though
it does not affect me fair enough
lord Mott's any credence any
correlations do you think with a
Nintendo and Sony stocks dropping post
stadium announcement
I mean that's really I mean like I
remember when when these rumors about
take to being bought by Sony what what
these rumors did I mean these stocks
went up like 4% or something I mean like
I would really pay too much attention
attention to to that because like it
just like you know market is
is dictated by like emotions and that
kind stuff right not necessarily the the
actual you know market I don't know I
mean I'm not to be I'm kind of like you
know kind of guy so but then I'm it
doesn't bother me at work but it doesn't
bother me at all
listen I'll jump in um I'm gonna attack
this from a different perspective thing
it's just at home
look stalks fall it's you know falling
fluctuating after announcement to me
it's funny it's interesting but I don't
get too carried away
Nintendo maybe today own drum I could
see them at some point you know linking
up partnering up with marks off if the
rumors are to be believed we game Pass
Sony on the other hand is in a different
position and um you know they have
remote play you know from the castle
view today's and expanded it to PC Mac
and iOS now and which access are being
to your ps4 but um and they also have PS
now which is the official or streaming
cloud service which they purchase from
god card but I gotta be clear on some
things I've been seeing on social media
they're not true you know this is in
regards to people saying penis now is
exact same thing exact our stadium that
is not true
first of all Sony currently does not
have the data centers nor the cloud
infrastructure like the big players like
Microsoft Azure Google Amazon and a
streaming platform PS now's max
resolution is 720p across the board and
they only have a few PlayStation 4 games
and it's primarily an older catalog of
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation 2 games
from a technical standpoint it's not in
the same league as project stream was
doing last year when 1080 60 you know
saying and now what they gonna propose
with the 4k 60hz are and then obviously
you have game pass you have X cloud with
the game pass librarian exclusives they
and they backward compatibility
you know enhancements and all that so
for gamers to say you know streaming is
not for them you know saying I get it
but let's stop grouping all streaming
services together like it's the same
thing there's a reason why there was a
minimum stop drop no said Sony has been
dominant as far as the console current
generation we now go act like distress
streaming future is super bright unless
we hear some to type of announcement so
that's all I'm saying so again I say
doom and gloom for Sony all I'm saying
is we just got to be clear as it stands
right now until they announce some type
of plan they are
in that aspect that's all I want to say
in the markets always gonna continue to
fluctuate one company's always gonna be
ahead of the other there's always going
to be a leader in the market absolutely
Lord King you're finishing up you tablet
okay well um also the same the next day
I noticed a couple of moves by both
companies Sony let it be known that a
couple of the exclusive games was going
to launch on PC that automatically
elevated their stock back up to the
original falling point and then Nintendo
announced cuphead and they also gave a
nod to Microsoft so I believe that the
cuphead thing was you know fill sank I
had you know put that up there so do you
know the stocks can go back up because
when you're in a partnership with
somebody you want to make sure that
they're at their best
right so they saw Mike they saw Nintendo
take a little bit um y'all announced
today probably was gonna announce it
like closer to e3 to get a better impact
for e3 but being that you know everybody
was an uproar all over the stadium stuff
they decided to allow that to come out
the next day and Nintendo starts went
back up but also they announced which
was huge to me that Xbox Live
functionalities will be inside our epic
alright so they laying the groundwork
for y'all to watch this partnership
remember I told you google is a big
thing Amazon is a huge thing um and
Amazon is already in that space if you
didn't know like y'all are looking at
this space like this space is only
occupied and Google is stepping into the
space know Amazon has been in this space
my kids play on fire stick right now
alright but you know it has actual
hardware same thing Google Google has
they actually chrome thing um but those
two companies are a direct detriment and
the reason why I said a direct detriment
to all of us who want that hardware on
hand that you know the lead power
hardware will be looking for the
fidelity and stuff like that they are
trying to eliminate that right and once
that is eliminated and there
no barriers in between that the last
bastion is these companies we have now
which is Microsoft Sony and Nintendo and
the only way that they're going to be
able to beat these dudes back is I
believe they're gonna have to group
together and start fighting there's one
and I noticed that that next day once
the stocks take a dip
everybody got back gather their self and
push forward um did I think that it was
a huge thing with the stock dipping yes
because it's foretelling that just off
of announcement they can take a dip mmm
so when it actually is released what is
actually really gonna happen to these
stocks right nothing you saying and like
I said I mean Bella's making some good
points in the chat as well people need
to accept that tech is changing gaming
is changing the industry is continuing
involving it will never remain the same
change is constant stop fighting accept
it right
I definitely hear your point spells and
look it this is this is gonna be scary
to some gamers you know I'm saying
obviously the stocks even know it's
temporary we don't know how long is
gonna last whatever people have their
feelings their concerns with you know
certain companies so we have to see you
know I'm saying at the end of the day we
have to see the gamers are gonna dictate
where these things go and it also
depends on how successful the services
well i malicious precious like gamers
are just so precious there's no stopping
power
you said look I hear what you coming
from late this is this is interesting
times and possible paradigm shift I'm
gonna start off would I want the next
topic with addicts topic which is on
halo Master Chief collection some new
drop and I had no mic still again she's
not now it clicked I don't know what's
going on with this mic today but Oh must
be the connection but oh yeah so
basically it announced in our home 343
had Bonnie Rice confirmed no Master
Chief collection and play anywhere so
this was annexed Opik he was very
intense about this what do we feel about
no play anywhere from Massachusetts
actually what I feel about that mmm-hmm
you guys you've been out what 25 years
now
whatever we applied the Jesus out of it
that many games to choose from what do
we need to worry about a game that's
been a or a collection of games has been
at the turn of time as far as gamers are
concerned why we worried about that
mm-hmm well let me ask you this Bell
well what about from the standpoint of
you know this was a service that they
touted right as you know remember gamers
were upset that Xbox exclusives are
going to PC right I was a big deal like
taking my and going over to PC is not
exclusive day and day or being whatever
so now you know they announced the the
term became what was the terms solve it
was it was something something exclusive
they changed the term anyway yeah launch
exclusive exactly now that we got that
right and then announced a feature of
play anywhere which is okay if you
purchase the Xbox version and you happen
to have a PC you could own it on PC the
Windows Store for free so what do you
feel about that bells in reference to
people say hey this is Microsoft
backtracking on a service that they
introduced and this is you know I'm
trying to forget my inner addict dawn
like this is absolutely absolutely
yeah you can we know as individuals in
our own life you can say something one
day and mean it with all your heart and
then a year later life changes life
happens things change and so do your
priorities and you have to say well what
was no longer is and we're just going to
have to evolve and adapt and a little
bit of change has to occur unfortunately
the word change is like you know the
devil - game is ridiculous if you want
to change anything now and and say well
I know that we said this back then but
that was a few years ago and a lot of
happened since then technology has
changed the industry has a fold and you
want to you want to do something
different than what you said five years
ago that makes sense then but it doesn't
make sense now
it's like you've committed something
murder it is ridiculous
that yes I said that this is gonna be a
thing mm-hmm
but it's no longer practical now and
frankly if you haven't played the Master
Chief collection and you are concerned
about it not being on play anywhere that
is all on you hmm
all on you it is free in the game pass
right now go play the crap out of it and
get out of your system
fair enough fair enough Lord mods halo
Master Chief collection not part of play
anywhere your thoughts mods muted yeah I
mean it doesn't bother me that much to
be honest with you I mean I own it on
xbox and we'll be playing it on Xbox 4k
60 frames per second I got excited about
it so yeah 4k 60 frames per second on
the Xbox one X so you know like I wonder
what sort of PC where you will need
actually to play this game so that's
going to be also interesting but I mean
like it is a bit disappointing to see
that you know even though they were kind
of like you know promoting playing
anywhere and stuff and you know that
kind of raised a question you know
what's going to happen you know moving
forwards because like a you know if I
mean this is like really an old game
right so why don't you Jim I don't know
maybe they just want to make more money
off of the you know PC gamers I don't
know that vpr thing as well
and they are you know the fact that they
are actually porting it to PC and they
they hired like two different Studios to
do it because it's 343 is not involved
like not directly they are working on a
high low infinite although I think I
know infinite is going to be a play
anywhere last time I checked on their
website so it's kind of weird under it's
not on playing anywhere but you know it
is what it is looking are you chirping
in the back yes sir
like the great philosopher Bruce Lee you
must be like water
because if you pour water into a bowl it
becomes the bowl what I want you to
understand yeah they said you know
Microsoft and switch names no actually
what you've seen is a money grab cuz
ya'll said they say oh alright check now
I'm attacking Microsoft right now this
is a money grab y'all go see it right
they're gonna switch hands on you this
is how he did it
they said okay yo check it out oh we're
gonna put out their halo the Master
Chief collection over here it's like you
always play anyway yeah cuz if I got a
real good no you're not I'm gonna divide
it the full joint we're gonna give you
piecemeal we're gonna piece mail it to
you so you're gonna get this now you can
get this at a later date listen I
honestly believe by the time all of
those games come out on PC with the
scaling and all that stuff and y'all you
know y'all like to do y'all like that
I wanna max out all my you know after
you max out all your settings are your
wallet and stuff like that they're gonna
take away that store and put game pass
on it's gonna be there anyway so they're
just getting this money first did miss
an issue cash you know in this do for
you fools I was talking all that message
I got Master Chief over now Master Chief
was it because if we have the Xbox and
you got game past is already there so
there's no reason for you to be crying
and yelling about it don't kick the
screen just take a shout out the Eric
drives he said an Xbox gamers were bad
with the introduced play anyway come on
man just pay for it again if you want to
really want to play it on PC the game
came out before play anywhere was even a
thing so you know if that's the excuse
they're gonna use let them use that
excuse
can't poured it you just can't do it
whatever the reason is like you know
what it is like honestly like they're
thinking they're looking at it as as a
brand new launched it they're kind of
looking at the PC community as a
different audience in a lot of ways
fresh meat
yeah exactly so they want to give it
that new smell you know that new feeling
it as much as possible cuz it at this
point it is what it is a four year old
game like I'm not mad at them at all
I'll jump in
I gotta be the voice of addicts look
I'll be real I don't like it you know
say especially when they introduce new
features that they intend to support and
then they walk away from it but look I
get it you know this is big business
this is Microsoft biggest franchise you
know into a new market you know I'm
saying I get it you know steam hope they
I am concerned with this recent
buddy-buddy relationship with steam and
now like Maude said what happens in the
future would play anywhere going forward
right
well it'll be interesting to see like
all the new Xbox exclusives will they be
play anyway anymore are they phasing
that out so now honestly I think that
whole I think their whole microsoft
store and all that stuff is gonna get
the bushes and I really believe so I
believe they they're trying to push
their game past I understand game
patches they think that Microsoft Store
is a failure that's why it hasn't been
updated that's why everybody's always
complaining about the Microsoft Store
why have the Microsoft Store when you
have all Microsoft stuff from game past
why don't you just push that mmm game on
yeah I want to say something very
controversial
let's go bad because I was thinking
recently about the whole play anywhere
and you know I mean have you heard about
Windows core yes so the whole initiative
of like running 32-bit certainly windows
32 applications on Windows 10 right
stuff
um and that got me thinking because like
you know was it like two or three weeks
ago when Microsoft announced that they
will be allowing or should I say that
was really a leak or should I say a
rumor
Brad Samms was talking about it that
they will be allowing Xbox native Xbox
games on PC okay and I hear a lot of
examples guys very angry about the fact
that they have to pay for they have to
pay for Xbox Live and eggs and PC guys
they don't have to what if I were to
tell you that if maybe this it's a
tricky way of Microsoft making PC game a
gamers to pay for those games I mean
because if they will allow these Xbox 90
these Xbox games natively on PC I mean
so that that's basically an emulation
what if they would just basically put it
with all this system and all the echo in
like the whole ecosystem would be kind
of like emulated meaning if you play if
you go into if you are planning to play
those Xbox games on PC you will have to
pay for Xbox Live to play multiplayer
mm-hmm I don't know if the PC community
will go for that
I mean I mean I can see game pass I'm
which your game pass but I mean a PC
that open market and they've been so
conditioned to not play pay for um you
know online it's like I don't know man
I mean I'm not saying it's not possible
that they may not be thinking about it
or attempt it but who they will be
pushed back you know to me the Microsoft
Store and Microsoft games seems like a
tale of two X boxes it seems like you
know it's the Microsoft PC sorry and
then it's the Microsoft gaming side all
right and then you give some games from
Microsoft in there and they were trying
to do the planning where the merge to
two and I really didn't think it took
off I mean I play some games on my PC
and I really didn't think it was as
successful as it can be and then once
you start breaking stuff down and
streamlining things and once you got
that service and I think they're keying
in on the service because I honestly
believe game
is gonna be their vehicle in the future
where you're gonna add different things
because you can take something away
right you can take away certain things
like xbox live subscription right but
then once you merge the game pass and
Xbox Cloud together into one unit then
you can push that forward and start
charging a different service for it with
the same functionalities of Xbox Live
because it gets kind of redundant now at
this point where you have xbox live
games of gold for the month and then you
have game pass games that come out you
know it's like it's too much stuff is
being given out here yeah yeah I mean
it's gonna be interested to see this new
approach and again I think this news
would uh would play anywhere is it's
very key we got to monitor it right we
got to see what's going to happen apart
from what King said I think also I think
game press gets a name change I think
when they consolidate all of that under
the game pass banner I think he just
becomes xbox pass or what is something
like that name as the name goes and
they're gonna identify the entire xbox
suite of services wonder that one banner
profit out the Fonzarelli he said he
thinks would be like a game pass games
with gold kind of thing so ya see last
topic talk about the PlayStation 5 and
some are great racing news shout out the
Lord Moz we got them in a building all
fantastic article on the premier website
Lords gaming dotnet we only were the
only one to go for their latest news
right Mars will a fantastic article and
I'm talking about like I said Sony
hiring graphical engineers with great
racing experience on Lord mods I want to
give it to you man
like what why should we be excited about
this didn't we think that a ray-tracing
can only it was so great you know
resource heavy that it wouldn't be
practical for the next gen talk to us
okay well basically it's a kinda really
interesting because obviously when
Vidia presented the whole ray-tracing
thing I mean they were saying that the
only way you can actually you know
utilize ray-tracing is to you know buy
one of their cards right RTX which we
are super expensive obviously and stuff
and I get it because they they've got
some you know interesting tech inside
but it looks like that's not really the
case I mean like Nvidia already changed
their stance on everything and they
basically said that you don't really
need our latest graphics cards so
utilize ray-tracing it may not be as
fast on the US on these cards but still
you know developers will be able to take
advantage of it so I mean you may think
okay so what was so you know most likely
it's going to be super slow on these
cards but there was a there was a demo
made by Crytek and they were basically
showing rate racing running on Vega 56
right so I mean pretty much the same
sort of tag that Google's didya is going
to be utilizing funny enough right okay
pretty much so looks like Google Google
Cydia is going to be a right race great
racing capable as well so that's another
thing and obviously you know the demo is
pretty impressive even though it's not
using all of the right racing kind of
tech because it's only using ray-traced
reflections there was no shadows or
anything like that but it just goes to
show that developers are kind of like
getting grasp of this new technology and
they are finding ways to you know to
make it run faster unlike normal you
know graphics cards and also there's
also two things that actually happened
with regards to like PlayStation really
one is obviously I think that was like
three or four weeks ago actually three
or four months ago actually time to go
yeah so they were basically presenting
rate racing in GT sport at a special
demo and what we're showing about at the
very beginning of this year during
SIGGRAPH and stuff and that was actually
running that was basically GT sport
ray tracing so I mean we can only
speculate that you know it that would
probably run on PlayStation 5 or some
sort of like similar hardware right but
just recently there was actually a job
post where Sony is actually right now
looking for graphics engineers with ray
tracing experience so I mean all these
events like four or five events and and
stuff like just that just goes to show
me that even though we were like very
doubt doubtful about ray tracing being a
thing next-gen it may actually be a
thing and I guess this is going to be
our like this you know news new new
technology that will make a difference
because I mean if if it's used right
right it really looks fantastic honestly
so yeah I mean go and check my article
and I think the description baby Lord's
gave it that yeah exactly
check it out there fair test yeah I
agree I mean I think that um I just want
to Double Down like what a question in
reference to it like do you think again
if this technology isn't able to be
implemented in the next generation of
consoles like do you think this is a
game-changer almost to the effect of
like a an HDR so to speak
yeah potentially because you know here's
the thing
right racing is very very very new and
like we talking about like hardware a
lot but see the thing you know people
need to realize that it's also about
like api's and the software and drivers
right and like you know look at what's
going on on consoles when these
developers get a grasp of their new
hardware and they know they're all the
tricks and stuff they can really deliver
you know great experiences with the
great graphics and consoles because they
know how to optimize these game engines
for these for the hardware so same thing
will happen work with ray tracing so
it's a it's a it's basically like it's
this technology still in its infancy but
I think it will be a thing
Nexen in some form of you know but yeah
i mean looks like next-gen consoles will
be your ray tracing paper and i think
that's a good thing absolute let's get
up bells in as bells bells are you back
lady but i does playstation or does
retracing excite you for the next
generation of consoles Oh frankly I
think that it's just it's just a thing
that should be the norm
obviously it's it's not new technology
in the sense that Pixar have been using
it in their movies for a while now
Nvidia or all over it it's in graphics
card so it's it's not a thing that is is
new it's being used across the board
already and should be something that is
being used in a next step like this is
current gen technology we're talking
about next gen consoles oh yes it should
be using right it's pretty it's not that
complicated yeah I understand that it's
gonna take a lot of power but these
consoles I mean you you ask any elitist
about whether oh go ahead already
chasing and absolutely they can yeah
there's that something no reason that
this shouldn't be a thing and it's not
really all that complicated
so yeah ray tracing yes it's exciting to
hear that they're finally using current
gen technology dog bells hey Lord solve
ray tracing how excited are you
I mean I'm excited because I mean I
myself said I expect you'll ated it
because Nvidia had come out and said
that this was sort of their thing and an
AMD came out and said they weren't
necessarily looking down that road that
because IMD was was is are the ones
handling console tech I said well maybe
we're not even gonna see anything
remotely resembling ray tracing or their
own version of ray tracing and next-gen
consoles and then of course in video
comes out like no actually you can do it
with courage and stuff so it's
interesting and I'm glad that it's gonna
be a thing and in my a group mods I I
the fact that it's gonna be part it
should be part of next gen consoles is
great
I think once again no it brings the
baseline down a little bit right if all
of us were expecting you know at least
4k 60 everything right I guess the
expectation that's what people want you
will see that but I'm you know at some
point I'm sure they'll give you that
toggle option where it's like okay but
if you want real-time ray-tracing you
you might get 900 P you know 30 minutes
a doze don't be banging those what the
console can handle more about what your
take they can end up very safe yeah that
is true - that is true - so honestly
yeah I'm excited about it I mean I'm I
don't know if these first iterations of
these consoles are gonna be that or if
you know or if we're gonna see a mid
console mid-cycle refresh that they sort
of brings that to the forefront so I
don't know Lord King a premium gamer
there's ray-tracing excite you excited
the hell out of me enough to get ready
to go buy a new video card I could tell
you that oh that's no no no you know
what it is you know PC thing goes you
got to stay with the times regardless
the weather once I signed on I signed on
for what I'm gonna do I could sell my
cards they gonna go in for the new cards
but I saw the Star Wars demo of
retracing right before I even got to the
battlefield stuff of a real-time game
using retrace and I saw the Star Wars
demo and I I encourage everybody to go
check that Star Wars demo just put our
Star Wars never ray tracing it looked
beautiful look like the movie and I was
like wow that's great that would be
fantastic if they could actually do that
in game cuz you know Nvidia likes to
show you stuff that's never coming out
super tech demos and then I saw the
battlefield 5 where they toggled on and
off and then I saw the Metro Exodus and
with it toggled on and off and I said
damn that is something that I definitely
need um once you see it you can't unsee
it and you want it right and just like
Cognito said as powerful as these new
systems will be that toggle switch once
you put ray tracer long it's gonna drop
your frames down your resolution back to
the bushes and
right back to their 30 frames-per-second
crap like we at now so it's gonna be an
option I hope I hope these new systems
utilize that we know Nintendo will not
be utilizing them function go Tendo
friends yeah five generations from now
y'all gonna get that new technology
called raytracer
oh my goood a switch lander had to have
boom that just happened to you
look that I agree with most of the lords
here or the Prado is it you know look
it's it's exciting if both are Sonjia
marks off adopt it you know I wonder if
it's gonna be like the new HDR if the
next-gen curious to see you know from a
developer standpoint who actually adopts
it you know a lot King said we know the
resources are a tense but we must assume
like Mars is saying that these new
generation of consoles are going to have
to beef the power to be able to handle
it so uh that's all I got on it anybody
got anything left on ray-tracing Lord
mods you're good to go
mods is good to go let's get out of it
alright new ILP poll this week with the
recent reveal of the stadia platform and
its intended release in 2019
who do you did has the most to lose with
Google's aggressive approach with game
streaming the choices are a Xbox stadia
is one year headstart already beats X
cloud at its own game be did Tendo
switch better partner up with X cloud
ASA see Sony PS now has to improve or
get left behind or D I don't care y'all
don't want that smoke with that Walmart
streaming service well it fails and it
ruins our reputation oh yeah that could
be easy that is the question those are
the choices please Rock the ILP vote
when it goes up on Twitter tomorrow lady
Bella and Lord mods thank you for coming
through the room and absolute pleasure
where can the 5 people find you let's
start with lady Bella where could if I
people find you what you got going on oh
they can find me
that's sterilized so really that's a
pretty much regular life right now just
at the bottle sterilizer yeah yeah the
washing machine I spend a lot of time
around the washing machine before we
cook baby so yeah anywhere between
making bottles and washing things with
spew on them is my absolute pleasure to
have you been so long I know our
schedules are tough sometimes and it's
really good to just see talking games
even if it's just a short period of time
really we've been friends for a very
very long time it's no just gonna find I
was really to get out of bed it so what
we know we know you put the extra effort
in to make this so we want to
acknowledge that so thank you again but
you know you will be back Lord
mods Poland's finest what's going on
brother that wicked if I'm people find
you what you got cooking up man yeah
well you know dropping some videos every
day you know so thanks a lot for having
me again on the show I love you have the
podcast and stuff obviously check our
articles yeah gaming you know very
interesting bunch of guys writing some
articles you know yeah you know very
very good stuff yeah and you can find me
on YouTube
mass gaming or Twitter mods gaming PL
and I have what's about some good
discussions absolutely we're absolutely
precious guys to the game some of the
best technical articles again on Lords
of gaming dotnet please check him out
man he's doing a fantastic job for us
and we're very honored to have him Lord
addict had to go he is at work so salute
my brother Lord solve waken if I'm
people find you what you got going on
yeah first off thanks to Bella and
thanks to monster coming through
appreciate you guys I know I know it's
not easy not easy
it's our difference it's not fun so
thank you guys for coming through
yeah you guys can catch me on Lord saw
ILP on Twitter and be accelerant on PSN
and xbox live and of course for all your
gaming news all you
related stuff go to Lords of gaming net
and of course like I said at the top of
the show to reiterate guys pay attention
to your family pay attention to your
friends just listen to them just listen
to match them make sure that make sure
they're alright you know and at all
times at all times and just talk to them
know and yeah man
yeah just whiskey love you man you get
if you get to focus on other people you
focus on yourself so much and you focus
your games new consoles so much that you
forget that other people are going
through [ __ ] yeah absolutely
what you're going through sometimes it's
about what other people go in here and
let me tell you I I think probably even
being on here today you seem that my
perspective from say a year and a half
ago when I was on the podcast has
completely changed I unless this about
worrying what will won't happen and more
worried about let things happen and see
how they they unfold you know you know
so many times we we see people going
through things and we just don't even
acknowledge it because we're so focused
on ourselves it's time to not be focused
on ourselves focus on everybody else as
well cuz you know one without someone
else
absolutely you see kind of any brother
good for mommy effect
mommy affected Angie you know I mean I
really I really didn't make it out of
the hospital with her Wow that itself is
a massive perspective okay absolutely
Lord King the premium gamer fantastic in
the realm today where can I find people
find you what you got going on first
foremost I would like to thank Lady
Bella for Sean of three o'clock in the
morning my hat is off to you especially
I know you not getting any sleep with a
brand new baby I been there I have done
that and I am done with that so god
bless you and thank you for showing up
it's always a pleasure mam mam Mazda
jay-z of Poland when I saw you pop up
Lynn Hill
was on Twitter giving that smoke out
this week Oh backing off with each other
tweets thank you for showing up it's
always a pleasure you know having the
untouchable mods himself yes sir on the
show I think you can run with that
untouchable Mars that's fantastic I
remember okay so statues king of statute
is this week we got a break this week
people even more than last year because
we have some new challenges what Sony
Microsoft endo is gonna be crazy but um
I'm out of king of statues up and on a
whiskey it's gonna be a special one I'm
a really dig deep in this one it's gonna
be my first versus statue
y'all trust me you will want to see
these statues it's big one is the most
requested statue okay in my stack that
people seen they see if I pass them but
I've never did a deep dive into it and
there's the next one nobody's seen I've
only seen one person posted on the web
so this is definitely that that joint
won it because then you know I keep the
bullets in the chamber just in case
people act up so you gonna see this one
this one is definitely off the charts
then we're gonna put them head-to-head
I'm gonna put up a poll this week like I
told you it's constantly evolving it's
constantly changing I'm trying to give
you the best content that I can give you
so go to Lourdes gaming dotnet and you
can definitely see a kos up there you
can also see it on our YouTube channel
go to Facebook Instagram and Twitter
listen on Twitter I do three promo
videos that are not seen with any videos
those videos are separate encapsulations
of that stuff that the statute that you
can see alright so when you get a chance
to check them out there they're
tailor-made for you just wanted a short
little version with a little snack bike
just jump into that snack and just
real quick all right it's definitely for
you um so listen I just want y'all to
understand reach out to somebody if you
haven't heard from somebody reach out go
through your phone right now you haven't
heard from a friend for in a minute
go to your phone just reach out say
hello say brother or sister you've been
on my mind
whatever just say hello fax fax
fortunate take something like that to
remind us to do that but if anything
good comes out of something bad like
that it would be that it does remind us
all to do that right now
absolutely again thanks everyone for
coming through you already know um Lords
of gaming that Ned IOP all the good
stuff the audio will be up our
brother-in-law Kai box who will get the
links in the description all that good
stuff and of course support the Lords of
gaming on the website you already know
on the the showpieces king of statues
with King and that will be up on
Wednesdays at 7:00 in the morning of
course our last word with ebon tiss
that's our looter shooter destiny
division anthem all that good stuff we
had our good brother Josh reading from
Lords of gaming net and also my boy slow
mo blacks back slap from brat podcast as
well as um the scum cast and it was a
fantastic discussion please support the
Lords and just want to reiterate what
everything to say like you guys have no
idea like it's been such a tough day for
us but just to one continue to do the
show because that's what whiskey would
have wanted and also just to be able to
talk and laugh with you guys it's
therapeutic and like Bella said um look
we all go to stuff you know stuff and
our community is real man you know
depression is real a lot of things are
real check up on your brothers and
sisters check on your games and brothers
because at the end of the day man life
is too short and this is just video
games we love this thing this is a
passion we can continue to do this I
miss you whiskey love you condolences to
you and your family and we're gonna
continue to honor your brother everybody
enjoy your Sunday peace this has been
another